elle est globale voir tout de suite face
à marie josée le picard a tourné un
reportage alors on va voir tout de suite
des modèles chanel décrit cette
collection que vous allez commenter
voilà c'est le même tailleur exarchat
inès de la fressange porte aujourd'hui
sur notre studio ce qui est lui présenté
d'ailleurs
alors j'attends vos commentaires pour
expédier la silhouette bons jeunes
élevés l'écrit très léger élevé des
garnitures de nouveau mais là c'est sur
une silhouette tout à fait différente
elle faisait elle adorait les plumes de
coq la gagne que des collègues du privé
sur une baisse tqs un très bon lm il la
voyait brouiller les tailleurs avec des
gants ont réveillé la douleur ce passage
là voyez cette huile est dans les
métiers fait dans des proportions
d'aujourd'hui avec des boutons c'est qu
il la voyait comme un gars non vous avez
très chanel mais elle fait déjà mais
cette silhouette mais ça n'a aucun
rapport
aujourd'hui c'est comme ça parce que on
a envie de ça ce qu'il faut donner c'est
l'idée de chamelle sans que ça soit un
vieux ringard pour le musée c'est pour
les femmes d'aujourd'hui c'est pour la
vie d'aujourd'hui c'est pas pour
habiller les gens ivres de passéisme où
l'émir qui ne compte pas pour la mode
inès de la fressange c'est votre
sentiment c'est comme ça que le mode
doit être vu et écouté oui je crois que
tout récent karl lagarfeld à réinventer
des classiques chez chanel se dire que
les gens descendre ça fait tellement
chanel elle n'a jamais fait ça alors
tant mieux mais de toute façon la
plupart des femmes qui sont là des fils
meurt dans vidal et roxanne est un signe
moi je remarque une chose parce qu'on
l'a déjà remarqué avec les autres
couturiers qui sont venus cette semaine
les robes sont courtes cette année
incontestablement revenus oui mais vous
avez l'histoire des sommets g20 montre
le snus était valable il faut sonner
faux tenons aujourd'hui vous avez une
femme si elle a des jolies jambes elle
peut les montrer quand même montré ses
bras et un coude et genou aujourd'hui on
a plus de différence à se montre je vais
pas aujourd'hui je trouve qu'une robe
décolletée très contrôlée par avec les
jambes gainées des bas noirs
c'est quand même un décolleté à l'envers
juliette has montre jeudi à plus
problème fonctionnel vous fera lévis
comme si elle avait la gym est
aujourd'hui être la première et surtout
d'y rêver les midinettes
alors là on continue à voir des modèles
de la collection chanel ce sont les
robes du soir
oui oui là c'est pas tellement chanel
mais elle est mêlée côté baroque
justement tout l'appartement était très
baroque rémois l'inspiration ces actifs
qui a été donnée de lui qui a été donnée
au théâtre de la reine à versailles
hélas la mariée elle ne fait jamais
gagner alors on ne veut pas dire que ça
fait jamais le pas chanel en tout cas ça
fait très inès et la prière car la
girlfriend quand même qu'on
l'applaudisse où il va être bien qu'il a
voulu quelqu'un voilà non mais pour moi
voyez iv channel schannel say never la
différence moi je trouve que c'est
chiant c'est le souk al qubaisi pas
victime de la jeunesse comme beaucoup
d'autres d'ailleurs je peux le faire
avec des passants beaucoup plus dégagée
si je ne faisais que ça ça serait
beaucoup plus dramatique au beaucoup
plus conflictuel des comme ça je suis
très dégagé je le fais avec gaieté et
enthousiasme et avec une équipe que
j'adore et avec inès qui est pour moi
l'image de chamelle alors signé de la
présence d'abord bienvenue puis c'est
vous est une habituée on s'est vus
souvent au journal d'antenne 2 justement
parce que parce que vous êtes finalement
le seul mannequin en 1987 qui est une
vraie star
bon vous le verrez bien toute façon donc
comment vous vivez ça et comment vous
expliquez ça surtout pourquoi les dans
les autres maisons de couture ya pas
l'écho des mannequins aussi célèbre que
les plus opulentes betty n'a par exemple
pas le problème des rigaud qui ne
veulent pas une vedette
ah oui mais et puis aussi peut-être que
peut-être que ce n'est les couturiers
qui n'ont pas beaucoup de talents
certains veulent justement être la star
et que quand on peut s'effacer ou pas
avoir se sentir obligé de montrer son
autorité ça veut dire qu'on a énormément
de talent et pio talent et de toute
façon flagrant on n'a pas besoin de se
doter de mal pour le montrer et ça pas
autre couturier ne supporterait pas
justement
d'avoir quelqu'un d'autre dans la maison
qui n'était pas aussi photographiés
interviewés la roche-chalais fait pour
toujours pourriez pas passer dans une
autre maison de couture
non c'est encore dans trois ans et après
un gros transfert comme la musique
serait la personne la jettera sourire
non vous y opposeraient formellement
gênant et je me jetterai au passage
barrage de notre exactement exactement
ligne f
vous êtes une star donc je les dis on
c'est vous êtes souvent invitée dans les
médias est ce que ça vous fait ça vous
tente toujours de faire autre chose
aussi télécinéma à moi ça n'a jamais
tenté de faire du cinéma je trouve ça
casse pieds on passe son temps à
attendre dans les studios non mais la
télé vous aimez bien à la télé j'aime
bien d'abord parce qu'on répète pas on a
eu cinq minutes avant nous a dit qu'on
peut dire des bêtises personne ne peut
vous arrêter ces compagnies ne veut pas
venir me contaminer la en courant et
bien un truc pour couper comme ça bip
non ils osent ils ne font pas envoyer
ses formidables la télévision merci
signé de l'offre étant je vous ai pts
toujours la bienvenue
merci karl lagerfeld et donc c'était la
collection chanel demain d'autres
couturiers d'autres collections de
automne hiver donc 87 88 fait cette
édition du journal merci d'être resté
avec nous le prochain rendez-vous est
l'information ce sera le journal de 20h
je vous y retrouverez avec plaisir à
tout à l'heure
à présent pour les infos à la radio